the preliminary stage of the skilling
open is officially
complete and here in front of me i have
the game hikaru nakamura
against alireza ferucia from the
penultimate round
round 14. and boy this was was a great
game i
enjoyed this game uh a lot which is the
reason i chose this
out of the bunch so let's take a look
e4 from nakamura and here farouza
chooses to go for c6 this is the movie
makes when he wants to draw the game
a very solid opening the karo khan
he his main weapon is
the classical sicilian that is the
weapon he chooses when he wants to win
the game he has played this several
times during this tournament
as well but now that he needs only a
draw
to qualify c6 is a move that makes a lot
of sense
so nakamura goes for the main move d4 d5
knight c3
takes takes uh nakamura play no furisha
plays uh bishop f5
and i can mention that knight f6 series
is another
another main move played that played a
lot and a lot more recently
as far as i can tell but ferocious goes
for the classic bishop f5
93 attacking the bishop bishop g6
h4 if white wants he can he can ignore
h4 and just play knight f3
and then something like bishop d3 this
is known as
kind of a very boring boring line but
it's
uh it's a very safe way to go
with uh with easy play for for white
but sort of easy player for black yeah
as well
however nakamura goes for the more
critical h4
and also the main move h6 h5 was a
threat
knight f3 knight d7 h5
bishop h7 this is all a mainstream
theory
bishop d3 bishop takes queen takes
e6 bishop f4 another main move is to
play bishop d2
play it a bunch but so is bishop f4
queen a5 check bishop d2
bishop b4 c3
should be 7 c4 attacking
the queen and this is the first surprise
it might just be my my poor theory
knowledge
but as far as i can tell i've never seen
queen b6 in this position before
i have seen bishop before here played
i've also seen queens of seven
and i think this position here
is a mainstream mainstream theory played
like a lot
in a lot of games because it sort of
transposes to the
bishop d2 variation here instead of
bishop f4
but queen b6 is a new move to me but
it's probably played
before and here nakamura chooses to
protect the pawn with bishop c3
i like that move very logical he doesn't
want to castle
long he wants to go short instead so
we're gonna see what happens
knight of six and he jumps to the e5
square a really nice square there on uh
on e5 rook d8
threatening the knight on e5 queen is
forced to move to e2
bishop b4 that is a move i also also
like
this could potentially be
the reason why bishop the c3 might not
be the best but
i did like the move but here
through you should exploit exploits
bishop c3 because you do not want to
take
because if you take here then you're
going to be completely
completely lost because it's not
possible to play queen d2 because we
simply take and take on back on e5
and there's a pin on the pawn of the e4
so playing king f1 would also be very
bad after knight takes c5
d takes e5 and rook d2 with the winning
position for black
so that is uh not so great so nakamura
decided to castle
takes takes and now white has
double pawns in a c file but in return
yes the b
file castles rook b1
there we go playing in the b file queen
c7
f4 getting a tighter grip on the knight
on e5
c5 this is a move i also really like
kind of fixing these two pawns right
here and also attacking potentially on
d4
queen f3 attacking b7 but it's easily
dodged by by knight b6 which is yet
another good move by
ferruccia is aiming at c4 and also at d4
rook d1 protecting d4 knight ft7
trying to get rid of the annoying knight
on e5
knight e4 you should pay attention to
this knight on e5
this knight has a has a bright
bright future you will see why soon
c takes d4 c takes d4
and um you know what they say
they say that uh fortune favors uh the
bold and that is definitely the case in
this position
where ferugia has this move knight takes
e5
d takes e5 rook takes d1
rook takes d1 and simply queen takes c4
the attack for white is pretty much
non-existent
it's not so dangerous and black has
an advantage of two pawns
it's perhaps better to to take with the
the
f-pawn however it's still not too
dangerous after queen takes
c4 knight to six black can simply take
on a2
and this sequence of rook a1 queen d5
queen takes knight takes rook takes a7
is kind of forced
and it's at least better for black
black has nothing to lose here but
flight has enough compensation
that it should probably end in a draw
with correct play
but black is uh doing well
however for russia he does not take it
he does not go for it he goes for f5
instead
and maybe he underestimated nakamura's
next move
which is a very strong move that is
knight c5
just sacrificing a pawn
takes takes takes queen h2 i really like
this play by
nakamura it's uh really dynamic
and now we see how strong this knight on
e5
is the g6 square has now become
a very attractive attractive square
right there
queen c7 a4
now a5 is in the air with rook takes b7
so farusha decides to take on d1 root
takes rook takes d1
and rook d8 and it does
turn out this natural move
is extremely logical
but it costs alareza varusha the game so
you can try to pause the video and see
if you can
if you can spot nakamura's tactic and
his tactic
is very well spotted here it's
beautiful it's a beautiful continuation
just before i get to that i can mention
that any move here is good for black
something like rook c8
would have been would have been
very good you can maybe ask yourself hmm
was rook d8 a mouse slip
i think it was a blunder but could also
have been a mouse slip
you know you never know but something
like rook c8 here is
is very simple and maybe queen b3
queen c5 you can't really you can't take
yet because of rook c1 but
you can play queen c5 and now something
like a5 take the pawn c5
this is kind of a funny line
i take knight d5 rook takes pontex
queen takes queen h7 king h7
and this will end in a draw after queen
g6 queen of seven
which will be a perpetual or
even this followed by queen g6
king jade and queen e6 check that it was
a long analysis but that is a way the
game could have ended in the draw
pretty dynamic position but
after the move rook g8 queen takes p7
wins the game it is a beautiful
beautiful move
utilizing that black's king is extremely
weak the king is the queen is
lured to b7 and
now the rook is unprotected we take the
rook and then we play
knight g6 and the mate threat on
h8 is extremely hard to defend
and the only way to do so or the only
ways to do so is to play queen a8 or
queen c8 but unfortunately for farouja
this end game here is completely lost
this past pawn here is just too strong
i mean we have the same amount of
material five pawns against the five
pawns but
this pawn here is worthless and this
pawn on c5
is just way too strong so the advantage
the computer gives here is a plus six
which is
which is pretty wild but uh there's
simply nothing black can do for example
king f7
king f3 king eight king e3
kingdom seven kingdom four very logical
continuation from
from both sides a6 and then
king e5 king c6
there is not much else you can do if you
play knight a7 that is met by knight f8
king e7 and then simply knight takes e6
we will take on f5
and the position is
recitable king c6 king takes e6
king takes c5 simply king f7 and we'll
take g7 and h6
king before king g7
and alireza resign so this is very
unfortunate for
uh for alireza because he ha he had a
very good position after
as we did see here after c takes d4
his position was pretty good and also
after rook takes d1
the position is more or less completely
equal
and whether or not it's a mouse slip or
a blunder
queen takes b7 here is a beautiful way
to end the game
and it was well
executed by nakamura afterwards but
the position was simply hopeless for for
black so very unfortunate for alireza
and before we end i want to show you
guys
the standings here after
the first three days are done you can
see how close it was
um maksim anishikiri alireza and
lim kuang li had the same amount of of
points however tie breaks decided
ali raises and liam's destiny
so they are both out of the of the
tournament
and this was very unfortunate for
alareza because he also ended up
losing the next game against liam
as well so he essentially only needed
half a point out of
two but he lost both games and he
is out by tie breaks barely behind
anisha
geary so extremely extremely unlucky
for him that's
that's just a brutal reality of uh of
chess
i've been there myself but
uh it will be exciting to see the
knockout stages
uh tomorrow and stay tuned
for more great content
soon coming your way